das hier wird die essensausgabe meine
damen und herren und das ist die
revolutionäre neuerung die 40 folgen
dicht machen müssen aber jetzt kommt sie
und herzlich willkommen zu minecraft
niveau mit dem kontrast wie sie wieder
am start nach meinem tod in der letzten
episode endlich wieder es ist montag
montag montag
und schon wieder montags ist schon
wieder montag ist er über grund mit
kontraste und chaos in seinem mit zwei
minuten die wir müssen wir unser lied
singen wir gehen jetzt noch mal ernst
nicht mit mir leid die wir nicht mehr
wollen oder nicht
wieso auswendig lernen hast du
eigentlich
ich hatte noch ein rucksack bei meinen
bei meinen sachen dabei wo ich gestorben
bin hast du denn noch
ich weiß es nicht und wenn dann bald
dich so nein das ist das ist goldener
rucksack der wenn ich meine sachen drin
wichtige dinge die mir mein leben
bedeuten den hatte ich aber nicht sofort
bei mir wenn ich wenn du jemand ein
rucksack findet es ist einer da gehe ich
vielleicht noch mal die hölle und knapp
nein das würde ich doch nie tun liebe
kinder als ob ich noch mal in die hölle
wer bin ich denn ahs ist jetzt los
was manchmal kommentiere ich so etwas
ist was ist kaputt ich dachte jetzt im
untergrund wissen dass mama als auch bei
mach dir keinen kopf und danach ich
wollte endlich mal meine kiste sortieren
ich komme mir vermieter muss jetzt hier
gab hier komme ich nie genau hier kommt
man nicht mehr durch frist google kann
man den kommentaren auch erklären wie
ich das wiederum stellt dass ich wieder
hier suchen kann
in diesem in diesem großen dingen wie
man kräfte und sogar zum inventories
nervt total
ich will dass wir unterstellen dass es
ab sofort einen stall you bis ich es ist
boden geht es im boden
was ist im boden ein schoko seien
zerstört 1 111 x 120 x 1 meins meins
meins bisschen klein vielleicht
erstellen na gut es wieder draußen das
ist jetzt mein chocobos stall so die
essensausgabe meine dauernd hören wird
öl hierhin scheiße jetzt hab ich
natürlich ran ehe das ist aber kein weg
das so plane
das ist aber ja ich bin konnte kraft und
schlägt ein bluthund 12345 datei ist
dabei ein bisschen großmutter habe ich
soko single do do witzbold habe ich es
wieder so aber habe ich groß wurde
richtig gefragt weiß ich dann nicht so
genau
jetzt habe ich wieder meine goldene
feder weg ich bin so blöd nicht länger
du bleibst du bist
ganz oft schreibt also wie die uns aus
glattem dahin zwei versandhandel mich
noch mega miese dieser eine episode
und jetzt fällt er selbst glaube ich
immer gestoßen aber trotzdem digital
video der sowieso nie gestoßen ist ja
auch man logischerweise aber schade
meint obus behindert ich hatte von da an
und jetzt ist also café du machst nicht
voll oder stay so würde
jetzt probieren aber meine ganze scheiße
hier von von da hinten in dem portal
mittlerweile so ich finde mittlerweile
so herzlich stimmung irgendwie
überstehen wenn du singst
das ist aber bei dir wenn ich weiß ich
sie beim pegel ja der ist liegt bei 1 5
promille und das übersteuert sicherlich
nicht 05.02 weg hier
geile sache so hierhin und dann kommt
hier der selbstverständlich ist halt
einfach so kilos was so etwa mit dem
untergrund bauen
der untergrund ist so schön denn sein
führer ist der beste oder im iso sowas
ist war die saison
denn der gründer blablabla irgendwie so
was tolles
ach da hab ich noch elektrisch ist dann
kann ich mich gleich noch ein flug staat
machen
bindow kg brauche ich das im moment
freunde ich muss mich kurz mit dem
kräften beschäftigen und dann bin ich
gleich wieder wieder da für euch und
beim beim luca und machte mit ihm beim
untergrund main zu beim über grund es
ist so traurig dass ich immer
verwechseln das ist echt du bist du bist
noch nicht so ganz hin noch nicht so
ganz drin nur so halb bisher
wo habe ich dann meine attacke hin
gepackt dahin noch in die quartiere
nicht drin
da habe ich mir gemacht stark gruber
das finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt
persönlich ja ansprechen so ist das
privat abitur direkt durch die tür
abi abi tür so dass sie mich aber mal
alle 32 mit noch zu einer hin da oben
dann auch die metro in doha der wurde
aber schnell wieder belebt manche
die kamera weg stichwort schreiben wie
kann man immer nur von irgendwo
runterfallen das ist ja ist ja peinlich
so dass hier wird die essensausgabe
meine damen und herren und das ist die
revolutionäre erneuerung die 40 folgen
hätte machen müssen aber jetzt kommt sie
königs zeitweise wurde wurde ist dass
herr luca zu lang 12
fünf tage sind ein totes tier neue
zeitalter sinken
kennst du das wenn die anfängt die
rutsche aus der nase zu laufen während
du nimmst dann wenn die sachen die ein
erzählt das ist ja einfach nicht kennst
ich muss das jetzt geschehen manchmal
fast ich mir an die nase wörtlich
aufnehmen alter weil ich mich wo ich
koks ja grundsätzlich bei gefängnis
direkt aldi oktober statt
schleck schleck schleck man schmeckt
guck dir das hier ist die essensausgabe
du wenn einmal zu fressen bildern kann
aber den ball nicht mit dem update wird
ja auch endlich den geben dinge das
unendliche flug stäbe ehrlich ja aber
scheiße damit nur noch geflogen
ja nur noch geflogen
dann finden die partien dragon ball z in
der hofstatt geräuschvoll
was machst du da alter dass die eltern
mein idol nach studiert das auch schon
mal im leicht gemacht kommen ist kein
ding drin
solange ich nur ab und zog sich zudem
leicht gekokst keine ahnung ob das echt
wahr oder nicht das ist mir ehrlich
gesagt auch relativ dicht war
sowohl wo bist du denn dann könne man
über grunde hauptquartier
ja auf jeden fall ich meine karte und
die essensausgabe hier ne ja gut dann
kann ich so lange noch ein bisschen bei
dem opfer um baumeln
ja auf jeden fall wenn du da zurecht
kommst von mir aus natürlich komme ich
dazu recht das ist ja nur nur volk
wieder mops drin und so aber die man ja
alle platt mit meinem beim schwer so der
nur acht jahre völlig cool da will ich
erst mal zu gucken wie du damit klar
kommst und wenn ich die man hier heute
da damit geht ein bisschen schicker
leben und wälder äcker treffen ganze
scheiße was erwartest du public zentrale
aufgaben mit ich bin grad mit meinem
ärmer harten schwer weil ich weil
normales dimensions wortmann der kassen
angriff macht ergreift mich jetzt nicht
an ich habe keine rüstung an
ja bestimmt helga ich habe ich auch
nicht angegriffen nur so ein bisschen
geboxt das denn an das ding das gar
nicht angehe hahn kann ich leicht auf
packen was bringt denn jetzt vitality
also meine rüstung finde ich jetzt schon
sehr sehr gut verzaubert einmal
aussterben jeder drin ist so etwas
kriegt anderer und neues leben dazu ich
glaube das nicht irgendwie an einem
feuer schaden
auch immer ich glaube dass du du du
kriegst du kriegst du eigentlich auch
schaden nehmen
ich bin ich bin das wäre natürlich
wünschenswert wenn das so bleibt nur
kommt wenn ich jetzt angreift wird
integriert christoph sonnentag zack zack
zack mensch menschenskinder da drin und
fanal
doch jetzt mal das dauert mir eindeutig
zu lange ich muss mich mal irgendwie so
ein living metals ort oder ein ende
deines ort oder jenes firma ganz
sinnvoll doch jetzt habe ich hier auf
einmal die gefunden oder last er soll
einfach in dieser höhe skarke es
regeneriert sich einfach zu schnell
aber irgendwie fest kohl hätte ich auch
so was mit dem tafelobst allerdings
gesehen wie heißt der amerikaner der so
teilweise heute vorstellt alles werde
ich das gesehen
das trifft dich einfach mal ja alles
richtig hört damit kann man hatte ich
nicht nicht dass es also dieses dieser
dieser einem ob der da drin ist der ist
schon sehr nervig muss ich sagen
mary mac lukat reicht mir gar nicht
gewaltig mit deinen penis das jetzt
irgendwas kaputt gehen aber ist nichts
zu probieren
fünf mal gucken hier was könnte man dann
noch drauf packen power mal upgraden
beim liga obwohl mir empfohlen hastig so
nicht doch bitte ja kristlbauer ist auch
blau.de passant zu statt blau außerdem
dass er gesehen wie der macht genauso
viel schaden und der fig noch mehr also
der schneller
das war ja noch mehr macht genauso
schaden aber defekt noch mehr perfekt
auf jeden noch mehr egal
dicaprio was los so jetzt hier kommt
dann die essensausgabe hinterlassen als
sich einfach die kisten in setzte
man hier irgendwann den 5 das kann ich
sein muss sogar muss sogar scheiße her
musste so großen gut muss jetzt mit
leben ja gut am liebsten das ganze haus
noch ein tiefer setzen oder wenn ein
bisschen scheiße ja auch heute also
richtig heftig gibt mir nicht egal wie
alt ich schieße ihn einmal an drei
herzen verloren und ganz langsam richtig
richtig gemacht so ja ich hab ich habe
ich habe ihn als man manchmal kontakt so
sophie heraus richtig unangenehm
ja das war richtig angst vor ihm war was
macht der denn hier
du bist du bist ja so am anfang ganz so
ja alles ok alles cool ich konnte
einfach raus naja so sieht übrigens
ausländer sind ich dann an über grund
bauen
das brennt alles mal zu so sieht's aus
wir machen einfach nichts ja genau das
sind wir die kinder die kinder von yahoo
wahrscheinlich ja gute wollen wir
anfangen zu bauen
moment ich schaute dispenser an und spaß
man weiß man ist ein bisschen sport &
spencer nicht mehr richtig
du musst an machen ich habe immer
gemacht was ich aus gesagt meine tollen
steinchen damit bringt ja ich das
einfach mal alles in meinem inventor i
was drin ist und das ist ob ich aus ich
muss meine coolen steinchen mitbringen
wird verpassen
auf jeden fall bringt sich ag muss in
diese steinchen noch sage und schreibe
fünf minuten das wird bestimmt reichen
um hier mega was zu reißen
das hat ja meine steinchen ich war
richtig cool
nds holen da sind sie
ich gehe mal kurzem einen kiosk ich
nehme mir gesteht die metall geht das
ein bisschen flotter als ein flug statt
nur so in den kinos cake eaters kay
frage ich kurz hinein und werde dort mir
witzige sachen holen wo ist das geld
fehlt es nicht
top secret es gibt eine direktverbindung
vom über grund sogar zum king of skate
von rund die suche jetzt mal gehe ich
mich ihn versteckt
ja ja bis irritiert oder keyboard hier
der insta von rewe ja das ist nicht die
die geheime verbindung ich würde nie mit
dem er eine verbindung schaffen wie
draufsteht
ich mach doch kein schäden unbedingt mir
mehr kisten machen für meinen kiosk was
ist denn also jene treppe runter aber
wir sind ja und wenn es ein verdammtes
geht das geld sei aber echt traurig den
weg das kann bis jetzt findet den weg
als ob doch das ist jetzt kein scheiß da
kann man wirklich durch und befindet
dann ins chaos cave ist mein job ist das
absolut wirklich absolut keinen job das
habe ich extra gemacht um so was so
verwegen versteckt und cold cave ja ja
genau ja klar das freibad kfd st
denn was das hier ist ein motor co
es schwebte bei der lava es ist tot
heilig und tod wo du ja viel spaß du da
kannst du lange suchen bis sie das
gefunden was da dauert mein freund und
kupferstecher so jetzt muss ich mir mal
sortieren das brauche ich nicht was sie
mitnehmen möchte ist natürlich meine ich
damit meine goldene feder reingepackt da
und mein crystal ball wird ich mitnehmen
die gleich will ich mitnehmen den flug
stapel ich mitnehmen und ansonsten
natürlich viele
und dann brauche ich nicht mehr so viel
da muss ich hier noch ein bisschen was
durch die gegend kräften vielleicht ist
das jetzt ein spaß mit bist du da bist
dabei haben wir produktiv gebaut
ja auf jeden fall die jungen hätten sich
niemals ist es ihr doch wirklich du
kannst du kannst du durch moment ich
komme hier einfach mal gegen er seine
koordinaten 1000 1000 sx - 4000 ist
immer noch ein
ich sehe dann nahm ich hab dein flugzeug
starb dann guck doch mal
ja man kann sich hier drinnen verlauf
wenn in diesen heiligen hallen eine
höhle gib dich mal dass ich mal hallo
hallo conny so jetzt kommt also ein
bisschen verwirrend aber und man findet
irgendwann findet man durch ich glaube
jetzt nicht lange oder doch
ziel war diamanten ja ich glaube ja ich
hab den weg gefunden um conney bist du
da pinsky das cave kann man ja lang so
und da gibt es ja und das hier ist ja da
ist nicht viel fertig alter lass das ok
stellt wieder rein
ich hab ihn eingestellt ist gegen mich
willst du echt noch mal sterben
gerald bitte bitte bitte lieber was zu
essen
das geht oft brennt beide halbe leben
das ist auch gestorben
heiligabend starb weil ich immer wieder
aus dem tor heraus kommt nämlich nicht
nett ob man ja alles brennt und das echt
scheiße aussieht aber hey was soll ich
dir sage ich immer machen ich wollte
hier überzeugt organisieren gehen jedoch
weiter
brad einfach komplett ist
alles brennt das schöne an der sache das
ist für mich total toll verschwinden
solche braucht diese verdammte bahn hin
funktioniert überhaupt
eigentlich will dies das geht alles sie
kann gar nicht funktioniert nicht
sonderlich weit mit den mit der
konstruktion ja aber mit der planung
sind wir schon ganz weit
vorangeschritten
ich hab' ich denke ich versteckt weil
ich hab' ich hab ein painting gefunden
das kann ich jetzt irgendwann die band
dran ist es nicht schön über mein bett
kommen über mein bett bitte das war ja
das ist dass es jetzt so ein bisschen
aus wie in wien sn keller stadt los geht
es mit der folge auf höheren alter wir
haben mit dem rate ich muss noch eine
sache sagen ja was denn ich habe
als ich aus seinem links rausgegangen
minder aus deinem gang
ja da habe ich was entdeckt was denn
also etwas
ratet mal was entdeckt habe ein portal
nein quatsch
das portal hat sich gekümmert wirklich
ne was für ein portal wir uns wurde doch
ein portal geschrieben von bäumen von
stadt roth entdeckt und das hab ich dann
versteckt und du musst es jetzt finden
wir beziehen schon wieder müssen wir
müssen stoppen
kannst du aufwand pinky stinky
einzugraben die nudel optisch werfen
einen bogen weg der liebe freude sein
wenn euch gefallen hat wieder und wieder
einschalten wollte und sonst gehe ich
jetzt meine letzten worte fliegt jetzt
ganz kurz unsere stadt ja mach das mal
meine letzten worte sind ohne sinn und
ohne verstand der kondi der ist ja
niemand von seiner mama schnackt der
hand welche gekommen sind mit dem
versand geil und auf und hängen